and
welcome everyone to our expert webinar
uh strategies for vuca world
expert tips to make change a driver for
professional growth
our speaker today is shri krishnan who
is a digital innovation consultant
and a former senior vice president
robert bosch engineering
before i introduce shri i would like to
remind everyone how to use the controls
in webex
um please use the q a box to ask
questions
for sri which we will address uh toward
the end of the webinar in our question
and answer session
um the q a question box lets us queue up
the questions for him
the chat box if you want to make
comments
um and there will be one or two times
when shree asks you to
to respond to a question in the chat
please address those to the host and
presenter or all panelists
so that um in fact it's all panelists
please
so that shri can see those as well as i
and
we will also be doing several polls
and we're going to start with this first
one
first one is
how much work experience do you have
and how are you feeling today um
we're in a extended lockdown
i know that for our audience members in
india
things are not looking very bright on
the
covid situation so we like to ask how
people
are doing and how
your psychological state is um but we're
also very interested
in giving you an idea of how experienced
our audience is
and if you're watching through
linkedin live or youtube live you can
put the answers in the comments
we'll show the results in about one more
second
and
there you go so as you can see the
audience is a very experienced audience
today
um bimodal distribution but most people
have more than five years experience and
the next most
common is people who are still
in school and fortunately
most folks are at least doing okay if
not doing better than okay
but for the people who are not uh who
mark thumbs down we hope that the
information in the webinar will um
help brighten your day a little bit and
so
with that said i'm going to introduce
sri and sri krishnan is a digital
innovation consultant
prior to his independent career
he spent a number of years as a former
senior vice president
robert bosch engineering he's got over
35 years in engineering and business
roles
so he's got a lot of experience and
insight
to bring to his current role providing
strategy and innovation consulting
and coaching emerging startups so
for those of you who are in startups or
planning
startups of your own you probably want
to connect with sri after this webinar
so before i uh turn it over to sri
he's asked me to ask you this question
vuca is an interesting term and
how many of the folks out there
are familiar with it
just leave this open for a few few more
seconds
and as i'm watching the the answers
coming in
it's not surprising the result
okay and
[Music]
sure you're not surprised to see that
about two-thirds of the audience
isn't familiar with the term right
that's a good start okay and welcome
i'll turn it over to you thanks to what
good evening friends this is free
christian here
good evening to the people in my time
zone and good morning to the people
on the other side of the world who have
joined early morning
gives me immense pleasure to share some
thoughts
about what could we do for the
professional growth
that too in the scenario of the uka
world
i'll be talking in the context of people
technology
industry leadership organization a lot
more
actually was quite popular term it's
interesting to see now it is
probably forgotten by many but what we
are going through is the vocal now
it's about volatility uncertainty
complexity and ambiguity
this term was coined in or used
in u.s army college in 1987 for the
first time
to tackle the complexity of the world
put in simple words actually
a hbr paper says that it is hey it's
crazy
out there and i'm sure all of us
appreciate
with the pandemic what is going on it's
just the crazy one what we are facing
but it is not just the pandemic going to
be this is a going to be a recurring
phenomena things are changing faster
than what we anticipate
and it's important we understand the
changes around us
and be ready for the change so that's
going to be the talk about
and next slide please
this picture is actually from 2009
that was the previous if i can call the
economic pandemic
you can see the forces that were acting
at that time
it was about globalization the
technology the dot-com things were
peaking
many things were happening with the
internet world
also we had problems in the corporate
world with governance
all these all these required a complete
mindset of
adopting ourselves managing the change
and navigating
interesting with the human species is of
course when we are going through when we
are in it
we might feel down we might feel sad but
we come out much more strongly than ever
because we have come out of that crisis
and we are through the next crisis now
with the pandemic i am sure
we will come out of this also soon
and emerge much more stronger and then
ready to face it
but what is important here is these
problems i call them
unscripted problems in the world there
are scripted problems and unscripted
problems the scripted problems are the
well-known ones where there are case
studies available in hbr and you study
in b schools and how to handle that
the unscripted problems are the ones we
are facing for the first time
and probably if i may say the collective
intelligence of human species fails
miserably
for some period of course then we learn
from that
and improve continuously that's what we
are going through now
again it's part of the change the world
is never static
and that is the whole thing how do we
navigate your carrier
in this kind of dynamic situation the
hookah
let me go to next slide please
let's look at the poor ceo who is
responsible to deliver still
independent of the market forces
independent of the world economic
situation independent of the pandemic he
has to answer still the question on
quarterly results
if things go wrong in the world he has
to still answer
what kind of risk planning he was doing
but most interestingly look at
some of the statistics and results from
last year's what were their top worries
what were they having you see close to
80 percent
ceos regularly worry about the workforce
existing skills and ability to meet the
dynamic needs that's the key word
ability to meet the dynamic need
is where they are worried because people
have to be reskill people have to be
changing
the next one you see it's just not about
the digital skills
i think the entire world is going
through digitalization the most abuse
toward digital transformation
it's just not the digital skills which
we all know everybody talks about but
good old soft skills we'll see later why
it becomes more and more important
in addition to the digital skills what
we are talking
the last one again the global concern is
about how to
acquire retain and nurture talent
because there is a talent
war going on all the time let me put
this way there are
not enough good people there are good
people no doubt all of you are there
but there are not enough good people to
meet the needs of the industries
that's a recurring phenomena so there is
a challenge of the ceos how do we
get the great people into their
companies
make them stay and contributed
contribute wholeheartedly that's the
challenge the ceos are facing i will
just invert the problem and
from the people who are aspiring for a
great career this is an
opportunity actually it's not a
challenge it's an opportunity because
every company needs great talent and
if we are able to change our
perspectives
if we are willing to learn new things i
think the career is given
that's that's the storyline what we'll
be seeing further
next slide please
i will start with examples out of my
experience of course i come from the
i.t industry or more to be precise
engineering r d industry
and the automotive industry these are
the two things where i spend most time
so i will pick up some examples but i am
sure all these examples are applicable
to any industry you can think of
very similar trends will be there you
can draw parallels
let me start with the holy grail of
software engineering
the programming language let's just look
from
1960s this guy this video will show you
every five years what happened with the
topmost programming language you see the
fortran is the king
60s 70s still that's the topmost
language being used
you see cobalt slightly coming up in 75s
suddenly pascal has come to the top in
80s
and then c overtakes and attack comes
for a very very short period but c is
back as the king
in 90s and then came c plus plus
slowly emerging and then
suddenly comes out of horizon java
javascript in 2000s
and then you see later java has come to
the top in 2005
and then you see the change again what
is going to happen suddenly python is
appearing
growing 2015 and
wow there you see python is the topmost
one
if you look at these trends interesting
trends the initial ones
stayed for 15 years or 20 years or at
least a number one two three positions
but you see in the later years even
every five years there are drastic
changes happening
so that is the pace of change is
drastically changing
let's go through this poll now
as you can see we just curious to
understand when you started your career
if your software programmer what was the
language
you used for the first program and what
is the
language that you are using
predominantly now
it would be interesting to see the
statistics
few more seconds to go let's wait for
the pool
good i'm sure the results are there
i think this must be unstructured text
so there could be many many things
coming up
uh let me share the table it's an
interesting table
oh great
and
are you able then to see uh table is
there but too small fun for me
let me see if i can
increase the font size
are you good read it or start it's okay
is that better yeah definitely
first programming language c twenty six
percent that shows any five year plus
experience whatever that would have been
the thing interesting
interesting to see fortran and pascal
guys also
one among them i started with photon 77
so
and then what is the second one showing
matches 28 python next is java
so the trends are right quite
interesting thanks a lot guys
shall we go to the next slide please
yeah so we started with the holy grail
programming language
let's go one level up you may be a
system engineer design engineer tech key
technology expert let's look at what has
happened
with emerging technologies i am picking
up gartner's famous hype cycle for
emerging technologies first one is
this figure is 2015. i have circle few
things which are quite common technology
you know peak of the hype cycle in 2015.
internet of things
machine learning cryptocurrency these
are some of the things which were in the
peak
and just we are five years ahead let's
go to the next slide and see what are
the things in the peak
you see two things one is
explainable a another is embedded a
in green circles let's discuss this very
interesting thing because
previous one what we saw was machine
learning was there just starting
but in five years this ai machine
learning
has become all permeating it has entered
into every device possible starting with
your mobile phone
and in other other industries it's
getting into the edge
much more so it becomes more important
now
how are we going to embed a in the edge
that is one side second of course a
started with lot more industries which
are consumer
related and now it is getting into a lot
more
safety critical domains like automotive
like healthcare
where it is just not enough you can't
say that i collected million data points
and the algorithm came out
and this is the result you have to
explain how it is working to go through
the regulatory authorities
so it becomes important now you are able
to put the a in the edge
and able to explain how the ai is
working because lot of ethical questions
are coming if you are not able to
understand the whole
algorithm is working you can't put them
for use
and of course the red circle is a wild
card entry it's about
which was due to the pandemic social
distancing solutions suddenly that came
to the peak 2020 hopefully that goes
away next year
it may not be there so the point is guys
that
again if you are a technology expert see
the changes in five years where it
started and where it is ending
unless we are upgrading one is watching
these trends another is keep on
upgrading ourselves
five years is enough for someone to
become outdated
can we go to the next slide please
this is from udami again one of the most
popular online platforms you see the
technology skills this is a mix of
languages and technology so
this also shows a picture if you look at
2060 to 19 what were the top things that
people were taking courses their
tensorflow tensorflowchat but microsoft
azure architecture top three if i look
at our opencv
look at in 20 it is different
of course machine learning is there in a
different form but as fourth position
but look at the top three
so this is the change again five-year
window is more than sufficient
to look at what is the hot skill it's
completely changing
that's why this online learning
platforms are becoming more and more
popular because you can't find people to
again teach you
in in person many of these things we
can't reach at scale that's another
trend what is happening people will be
continuously upgrading themselves
with new skills with online platforms
let me go to the next slide please
let's come to the other category of
people in this
engineering ide organizations it's the
project managers
and other managers who are actually
managing the projects
sdlc models the software development
lifecycle models if i look at again
historically
it all started with the classical
waterfall model
which which is very interesting because
it never works like that the world is
never in that model
the waterfall model assumes more or less
you get a
well-written requirements document which
falls onto your hand from heaven
probably and then after that you are
ready to do
design you do the design design document
is finished
and then you start coding done do
testing and release
that's a fantastic model if the world
can work like that but never
soon people discovered that doesn't work
like that world is iterative
because customers don't know exactly
what they want
that's why you see i trade even
prototyping as the next two models that
came up because you have to show to the
customers
they can imagine to some level but they
will want to see and then only they can
further tell you what they want that led
to many of the iterative models
including the spiral and then again
the waterfall came in a different form v
model but it is little more structured
top down to bottom up how to envision
the beauty later is the v model can be
repeated in the nitrate tv multiple ways
can be there it's not just one week
and then came the
agile in late 90s and 2000s started the
agile
methods it's a spectrum of things
including
scrum and all all other extreme
programming and all those things then
came the agile manifesto
and then also became a habit kind of a
thing agile means there is no
documentation required you can do as you
it becomes like a free for all kind of a
system feeling which is not the original
agile intention at all
it became like software is like the
software cowboys can do that agile
programming again lot more structured
things started coming
and now agile is used in all safety
critical domains as well in automotive
are in healthcare everybody is following
the agile methods in various forms and
then it evolved into how do you do
system of systems
or scalable agile methods all those
things started coming up
so that's the evaluation what is
happening again if you consider if
you're a project manager
or a manager managing a group of
projects
you have to evolve along with all these
developments that are happening tracking
things what is the latest
interesting to understand what will be
the five years down the line the
software development methodology what
will be used
and preparing ourselves because the
ethos and philosophies of
waterfall model 2 agile model is
completely different
and if you're not able to understand
that and change the mindset it is not
just some templates and forms
it's about the mindset when you talk of
agile
you will become outdated as a project
manager so coming back to the same point
need to keep upgrading even if you're a
manager it's not just about attic
now i will move on to industries and
i'm picking up automotive obviously
look at this picture this was one of the
earliest automotive ad
i love this because it gives all the
essentials
as thought in those days what was
important
starts with the title dispense with the
house so that was the motivation for
an automotive save the expense care and
amp safety of keeping
a horse and then it talks the cost is
half center mile
and it can run somewhere 8 to 20 miles
an hour
and of course then he talks of some
technologies and says no order no
vibration suspension where
it's quite interesting what are they
advertising and price is thousand
dollars in those days you can imagine
but this is quite interesting what was
the purpose of an automobile it's
basically essentially a
is it's a it's a contraption a device
that helps you to move from point a to
point b
can we have the next slide please and
look at the latest
tesla model x ad what i have put here
taken from the tesla website
first of all does it look like a car
that's a big question mark
what is that talking of course tesla is
talking of lot of things
definitely about the power they are
talking of that
it moves from zero to
60 miles in two and a half seconds and
it has got about 350 miles range
all those things are being topped but
more than that what are they talking
it has got 10 teraflex
processing power and you can do any
gaming like you are doing at your
home gaming console how does it matter
in a car that's an interesting question
and everybody in the car can play the
game on the console that's what he says
and then he says there is so much of
connectivity with bluetooth
wi-fi and everything and
again there is usb charging ports for
you to charge
your laptop charge your ipad
or any other tab and all those things
image and for every passenger i mean
these are all becoming more important
features
of course it is given what is the power
of the engine or what is the
speed acceleration all that becomes
standard but you look at
what is emerging as a new technology
this becomes finally the car becomes
not a capture contraption that helps you
to move from point a to point b
but it is much more sophistication it's
a gadget on wheels
that's how the whole industry is
emerging
now if you look at this industry what
are all the technologies being used
it's a it's it's a plethora of sensors
you just look at the lower circle
picture there is a front
facing radar low range radar mid-range
radar
back side camera front side camera side
looking 360 degree view
there are so many sensors that helps you
to keep on the lane to do emergency
braking
to watch your blind spots there are so
many assistance functions so many things
and then if there's an electric vehicle
then you need the connection to the
charging infrastructure
remotely or you go and connect it and
you pay through your wallet
in the car or you pay through
your payment gateway to the tools
and you are always connected with your
mobile phone as well as to the satellite
and to the infrastructure and to the
mobile network so much data exchange is
going on
i mean it is no more it's no more about
the
device that was helping you to move from
one point to another point
and if you look at the domain knowledge
that is required
probably somebody who was an expert let
me say in
engine physics and about exhaust systems
was considered a techie some decades ago
today the same person probably if he
wants to call himself as an automobile
engineer needs to know a lot more about
these kind of connectivity technologies
artificial intelligence and sensors and
all that
these two ends of the spectrum can the
same person learn
or without learning can somebody become
an expert in automotive industry
as an overall level that's the question
what we need to debate as we go along
so the industries are getting much more
complex over time than in the past
excel please
and to manage this complexity what's
happening is very very interesting trend
what i call the vanishing borders
between competition and collaboration
people have realized to achieve a level
5 automation
that you can't work just like that
independently and try to achieve that
instead of strategizing how to beat the
competition the ceos have to think more
on
how to work together with competition so
that we can conquer the market
not the competition or create a new
market rather than capturing a market
you look at the some of the connections
here
it is ford somehow working with
volkswagen
working with apple and you look on the
right side gm working with honda honda
is working with toyota
all this would it have been possible
some decades back maybe in very small
scale
but today it's a necessity and not only
the
oems even the suppliers are working
together
forming joint ventures between the oem
and suppliers between suppliers
between many startups which are emerging
so this is the landscape that is
completely different if you are drawn
this landscape even 20 years back
that's a necessity because of the
complexity the only way to
conquer this complexity of the industry
is
only to collaborate and what you would
have seen i prefer calling them
as a tech mafia because these are the
new entrants who are nowhere in the
mobility space
who are actually started in the iit
space who are giving infrastructure
cloud and connectivity
and software that runs on your pc and
then suddenly they have come to the
forefront
providing you automotive now they have
converted the automotive industry as a
mobility industry
now we have an interesting poll question
do you see this
tech mafia as the market leaders of
mobility industry in future what do you
see
great eighty percent i think eighty
twenty rule applies here
eighty percent are telling yes exactly
that's the trend
and then what happens to the classical
automotive companies that's the question
if you see the new entrant like tesla
yeah next slide please yeah hold on here
so you see this is what is happening the
tech mafia
are what they call the fam gap it's
facebook
apple microsoft google and amazon
these are having the largest i mean the
market cap
in nasdaq also together holding they are
dictating the world
in automotive now many things how it is
going to shape
that's what you also said that you see
this tech mafia as the future leaders
probably and the profound statement what
i see is this was made by the daimler
ceo mrs hay in 2015 in
frankfurt auto show we don't plan to
become
foxconn of apple that's a scenario they
are fearing
unless they change unless the people who
have been in the industry for 100 years
150 years
change their outlook become little more
humble to look at what are the new
trends
where is it coming from and change
themselves it's not going to happen
now who are the people who are going to
make this change it's the leaders in the
company
that's the next topic i'm going to deal
with can we move to the next slide
please
if you look at leaders what kind of
skills are we talking leadership skills
on demand this is from 2018 world
economic forum report about future of
jobs first look at the red thing
these are the skills in 2018 which are
going down declining
coordination and time management this
was a classical skill of
a manager more than a leader but leaders
were also doing that doing coordination
arranging things
and managing time that goes down heavily
and look at the green dots which are
moving from 2018 to 2022 according to
their survey
it's about active learning and learning
strategies
that's the key even leaders have to
upgrade themselves
it's not only the people who are working
below but it's the leaders also have to
upgrade themselves by continuously
learning
then look at the other trend is
creativity originality and
initiative this again comes from the
worker world
and unscripted problems what i don't to
deal with
unscripted problems one needs to have
enormous creativity because you don't
have previous solutions to refer to
are the old wisdom doesn't help you
and what is declining the right side
picture what i have shown
what we call management by meetings
we all know typically how much time the
leaders spend their time as well as
their associates time on meetings
with lot of coffee coke everything
looking at charts looking at monthly
reports
looking at previous minutes open issue
list or open point list
tracking them and asking them to come
with the next set of points and call the
next meeting each meeting running over
time by
half the amount of the time i mean these
are the classical syndromes
of how leaders become dysfunctional
managing only meetings
and that's exactly is going to vanish
unless we change
move into the learning space moving to
the creative space
again leaders will become redundant next
slide please
so this is the radical shift that has
happened from the industrial age
management of
what we call the leaders how they were
where the organization was
if the if the organization was
hierarchical layer after layer
like a pyramid and then the mindset was
internal that means you look at cost
efficiency it's important not that cost
is not important and efficiency is not
important but the entire focus was on
managing the cost and efficiency and
the whole method of management was with
carrots and sticks
and the method of influence was
telling the people are ordering the
people and questing them
to do things and digital age leadership
is just the opposite of that it's a
network
organization we will see later it's not
a pyramid organization how it will
change
focus is more on external the focus is
towards
markets customers collaborators
stakeholders working with them together
and the way they are
going to do that is more of empathetic
way
empathy with the customer empathy with
associates empathy with the
collaborators
and lot more creativity to do with
unscripted problems
and then how are they going to do that
by really inspiring people
because the olden leadership model was
the industrial
age leader knew everything he will tell
the people what to do that's no more
possible in the new age digital age the
leader
or the ceo doesn't know answers to all
the questions
but he can inspire people he can create
avenues for collaborating what we call
the servant leadership
remove the barriers and enable the
organization that's the role of ceo
that's the role of leader how it is
going to happen that's the massive
change that people have to be ready to
face in leadership roles
next slide please
so that's the future of organization
what is going to be
organization is networked organization
it's no more the
hierarchical pyramid organization and
the ceo or the leaders are not the
pharaohs sitting in the top of the
pyramid it's a network organization lot
more connections will be there complex
connections will be there people will
figure it out how to work together
but that's an interesting change that's
going to happen second the organizations
are going to be project based what i
mean by project is project is defined by
purpose
defined by a timeline milestone
it is defined with a well-defined cost
well-defined goals and the end of the
project the team disperses
the classical what we call the line
organization
will become a thin line it's going to be
much more
purpose driven projects where people
come together and collaborate
then the third is what i see as the
culture of community
what do i mean by community there are
good examples in what we call the open
source community as an example how
software gets developed
things are by merit the leaders are
elected by merit
people join the projects because they
are passionate
and they give their discretionary effort
towards that
and they are so passionate to achieve
the goals the project moves much faster
than a classical other projects of the
organizations
so that is the community culture that
will come in future organizations as
well it is not that people will be
assigned to projects but people will
choose
what projects they want to work and
comes to the last one what i am seeing
is the gig
working i think the pandemic has already
created the impetus always gig is not a
new concept but now we have got an
enormous force happening
what i mean anybody can work from
anywhere for any amount of time
the engagement can be much more looser
than what we are talking today or
expecting a loyalty and lifelong carrier
will be gone
the concept of geography will become
history
people will work from anywhere to
anywhere so the talent pool is really
the world is the talent pool available
real globalization will happen even in
the workforce
all these are the changes that are going
to definitely happen
when is the question but it's going to
happen future organization
again everybody in the organization from
the bottom of the pyramid so-called
today's developer to the top of the
organization
people have to adapt the new style of
networked
purpose-driven projects and a community
culture
and having people who are going to work
from anywhere in the world in the game
that's a change massive change that we
are going to see in the future
organization that brings probably to the
next question on the poll
when do you see more than 50 percent of
workers being geek workers
5 years 10 years beyond 10 years what's
what's the audience view
be interesting to see that statistics
that emerges
again great to see sixty percent saying
five years
another twenty-five percent saying ten
years the answer is going to be
somewhere it could be seven years i will
see eighty percent people are saying it
is going to happen
and are we prepared for that is the
biggest question all the people need to
think
are we prepared for such a change for a
network organization gig
organization is a question
moving back to individual level coming
back to competency if you look at
all these challenges what we saw in the
oka world the changes that are going to
happen
even the model based on which we develop
competencies has to drastically change
once upon a time it was so much thought
that
depth was considered so important no
doubt depth is required
but we discovered the depth is not
sufficient you need the breadth also
of general knowledge so the i model
shaped model of
competency became the t model and then
we discovered that
one topic depth is not adequate we need
multiple so it became pie shaped
and then it has become now comb shaped
you need general knowledge which is ever
increasing and depth in multiple topics
just not one or two topics
because you would have seen just take an
automotive to call yourself an
automotive system engineer or to call an
automotive
domain leader you need to know so many
topics and it is keep changing every
three years every five years
it's upgrading itself so if you want to
be
really successful in the career let us
look at
both breadth and depth and depth in
multiple topics
that's going to be the new shape of
competency what we have to look at
and where the next slide please just
summarizing so far we are nearing the
end
what and all we have seen the complexity
of the bukka wall
we started with programming language the
holy grail
how it has changed initially every 10 15
years and now every five years
we say the technology trends are the
top of the hype cycle technologies how
it has changed in five years
we saw the complexity of the industries
in an automotive it is no more point a
to point b
it's much more and what kind of
technologies are coming into the
automotive
and we saw to deal with this complexity
how competitors are collaborating
and how new entrants are coming in and
we saw the leadership style
of industrialized doesn't work anymore
management by meeting doesn't work
anymore we have to prepare ourselves for
the network
gig community based purpose driven
organization
and to do that all the layers of
organization have to develop
competencies
not just in one or two topics breadth
and multiple topics
that's a summary what we have seen so
far next slide please
so now coming to the strategies how do
you survive this complexity
we learn the concept but how do we do
that how do we survive
how do we exist just not that how do we
excel ourselves in our professional
careers
first one i would say is learning to
learn many of us think
probably once a college education or
something is over we think we have done
with
education which is never true it's a
lifelong learning
otherwise we can't survive so first we
have to learn to learn
how do we learn new things allocating
time
planning topics making an annual plan
what do i learn this year
how do i upgrade myself what are the
trends
how do i learn new things because as we
age also learning abilities go down
how am i going to learn i'm going to
read
i'm going to watch videos am i going to
join a community
work with people learn together there
are many things to do how am i going to
learn
second comes creativity
associated is originality and initiative
it's not just creative ideas but we have
to do things with initiative
that's exactly because of what i said
the unscripted problems
require creative solutions and more and
more unscripted problems are going to
arise in the world
if you want to be successful in career
we need to be creative lot more
and third comes is multiple skills what
we discussed one skill
is not going to carry anybody's career
lifelong
people need to be developing multiple
skills and combining point two and three
is what i mentioned the picture that it
is not just technical skills it is just
not the soft skills
we need creative skills balance of right
brain and left brain activities people
need to
learn arts learn languages which
triggers different points of brain and
helps you to balance your logical
thinking as well
so that's the essence strategy if you
ask me my view is learning to learn
being creative and developing multiple
skills
continuously that's that's the mantra
that's a strategy that will help us to
have a successful career next slide
please
i would like to
ask this question quite interesting one
i will explain this strange looking
words here ankura
imparu but just can somebody make a
guess
who is this person an eminent person
here in this picture
you can you can put your answer
in the poll or type on the chat window
in this case put it in the chat chat
window please
okay please type in your answers on the
chat window
davinci interesting close by not exactly
it's not davinci
painter painter is right obvious
good i think the answers are coming no
it's not because so definitely
michael angelo definitely not rembrandt
i think let's go to the picture this is
the most interesting thing philosophy i
would say that
one thing if there is a takeaway for you
for me this has been the takeaway
he said this is italian pardon my
pronunciation in italian may not be
right ankoro
impero means still i am learning
and this was set by supposed to have
been said by michelangelo
at the age of 87 just imagine
he was past his prime period he was the
master painter
a master oh was respected and then he
said at the age of 87
i am still learning i think that is the
spirit
that will carry us forward and more
important i just wanted to put his
most famous painting of that also i
think all of us are familiar with this
painting but
there is a there is a very interesting
interpretation i would like to offer
this is my personal interpretation if
you look at the picture on the right
you may be a believer or agnostic
doesn't matter
i think that is where the genius of
michelangelo has worked
you can interpret this as god and man
emerge from
god but if you look at the
mysterious shroud around the image of
god
and angels that's very interesting it's
supposed to be some red cloth or
something in the air
but we know that michelangelo was very
well aware of human anatomy
and if you look closely it actually
seems to be showing the human brain
that's the mystery of this probably
probably one interpretation is he is
trying to tell us
if the human is human just because of
the mind
now let me connect what we are talking
here how do we keep this mind a
beautiful mind
it's only by lifelong learning we keep
it active
and thus we remain as humans the
society that always
evolves faces challenges but emerges
much more strongly
and evolving further i think that is the
mantra i would
leave you with ankura
still i am learning thank you very much
now we'll go for questions
from you
and give me a moment to bring up our
questions
we have a number of questions that have
come in from the audience
okay and
i'm going to bring those up in just a
moment yep
okay um prague asks
how to shift to project management after
two or more years in front-end
development
um he has a uh an mba and ms in
management
and find developing job very stressful
and boring
loves project management not only in
tech but in general i think maybe what
he's saying is whether
he should get it be mba or msn
management or other
so what how would you advise uh prague
should he go for an mba
what other types of uh tasks
approach to to shift into project
management
actually project management is not
directly coming from mba mba is more for
the business leadership as you know
project management there are enough
programs available from project
management institutes and
even product management if you are
wanting to manage a complete product
lifecycle there are enough
trainings and interventions available to
qualify yourself as a project manager
there are well-established methods and
well-established programs available
to become a good project manager of
course you have to practice along with
the theory
and there are integrated programs
available
okay um
we have
package sony who asked a question
directly related to the presentation
which is
does an automobile engineer need to know
programming
that's a good question this question
keeps coming about programming
answer is yes and no it depends on what
is your daily job
but question is if you want to manage
people you want to be connected with
them you can't be a manager
or a leader who doesn't understand what
is actually going on it's better to
know dirty your hands know a little bit
sit with the people and understand not
that you are going to write the program
every day
but you should be able to sit with them
help them if they are stuck
work with them understand then only you
will develop the empathy
that's important for that you need to
know little programming what are they
doing
that's the way i would put it but if you
are way up in the current way of
organization in hierarchy yeah you may
not have time or you may be already
outdated with respect to
programming as such but try to
understand the system level
the architecture level design level what
is going on that's important
uh we have a question from roberto
who uh asks where do you go or
what how do you
look for tech trends to keep on top of
those
that's interesting actually the world
with the
information explosion the digital wallet
has become much more simpler
to get the trends but they are not
necessarily the trends you have to
interpret in your account you can look
at gartner trends you can look at every
consultant publishers trends
if you start looking at top 10
technology trends you will get a million
hits on google
but that's not the point you need to
interpret each of the trends in your
context
the context of your industry context of
your organization
that is where the ingenuity comes
that is the difference what makes so you
have to make your own trend for your
industry for yourself what makes sense
but trends are available
but not the insights you make the
insights
um partha asks
how do you select the domains that you
should work on
to add depth to your breadth
according to you know cooling from the
t graph to the pie graph to the co
approach
that's a quite interesting interesting
question like it
there are two ways to approach not
necessarily you need to switch domains
it's good i'll come to that but even
within every domain now you find
there are things available from one
extreme to another extreme
i'll just take from automotive or maybe
healthcare i will explain
if you are interested in the core
physics or the core sciences
work on the side of an engine physics or
emissions and
how do you how do you work with that and
improve that or you work with battery
technology or battery chemistry whatever
those are the things but if you are in
the digital side you can work with what
i showed there the gaming console or the
or the user interface or the
connectivity this is another extreme
both come in the same industry you don't
have to switch industry for that
if you take a healthcare it's the same
thing the ai has gone into the
healthcare so much that
mri scan images are being interpreted by
computers you can work on the other side
you can go to the fundamental sensor how
to sense things in a human body
i mean you can work from either end to
another end within a domain
as well you can switch domains that's
welcome because the world is becoming
more and more driven by horizontal
technologies if you are an
a expert and if you are able to
understand the context of a
for an automotive and if you are able to
understand the a
context for healthcare actually you are
increasing the breadth as well as the
depth
that would be my answer okay
um bhaskar in our linkedin live
audience says he's aspiring to become a
enterprise architect
because it's not bound to a particular
industry
um it's working as a technical architect
specific in cloud and ecm
so what would be good approaches for him
to broaden his his perspective to get
into the
role he wants yeah
this is another interesting question
again enterprise architecture is good
because it is agnostic to any domain you
are horizontally working
but what you need to think is again what
are the tools that will come for you to
help you to design things
what are the new methodologies of design
that will come up
how different industries are adopting
different design technologies
because again every industry is not fast
enough you will find certain things
getting adopted in the consumer industry
faster
maybe some industries which are safety
critical will adapt slower
but you have to look at the leading edge
which always happens
with consumer facing and certain
organizations like that and industries
like that
so you need to track that and pick up
what domain interests you and you will
see the trends there and you can learn
out of that but
horizontal is good in that sense you can
work in any domain
excellent it's a question from venkat
um who uh so is
in the new uh
form of organization that no longer has
uh
long-term engagement of associates how
do you invest in talent or how do you
nurture a culture
if you're going to be relying on a lot
of gig workers
fantastic question this is the challenge
or opportunity depends on that for the
hr community or the leadership how to do
that
actually people are going to be working
because they are inspired
as long as you keep them inspired they
are going to continue for long term they
can work for years together
as long as you find give them
interesting problems they are going to
work
as long as you have inspiring leaders
they are continuing to work
the moment that goes away they are going
to move into different organizations
people are going to look for interesting
problems to solve
under interesting leadership and that
can happen in your own company
or in another company if you find the
ways to keep them
you will keep them then then that
becomes easy
but the rules governing the communities
what we see in the
software open source communities are
interesting actually people are sticking
for long term as well as people are
switching
but the culture forms there by
meritocracy and the purpose
and passion it's no more the leaders
giving lecture about culture
and values but it evolves actually there
are much more stronger values you will
find among the communities how strictly
they follow
and how they stick to the values i think
such new new new trends will emerge
that's my view with gig economy okay
um we have a question from kishore
who has five years in it project
management
and would like to shift into devops
project management
um what would be the kind of planner or
certification path that you'd recommend
form so i've
i've got a thought on that as well i
think
project management is essentially the
same it's not about project management
but having the right
technology knowledge and domain
knowledge with devops and as i told the
processes also will be different with
devops so
to develop those knowledge but
essentials of project management are the
same
so you should go ahead and understand
the technology work with that
how tools are being used what is
actually devops how do you make a
release
in a devops environment those are the
knowledge that you need to build project
management if you have done for five
years then
you are quite good with that right and
just as a point of information
simply learn does have some good
certification programs in
devops including a
partnership with caltech the university
so
um i would say
um kishore if you take a look at our
website you you'll see some
information that will help you in that
particular direction
um but sankat asks a more general
question
um since he's confused you know which
which skills um
since he's he's got a broad interest in
almost every skill that he
he comes across which skills are in the
most demand or which are the most
strategically important for developing a
career right now
my answer will be slightly different
here actually it's a great asset that if
you are interested in multiple things
you find your passion what is attractive
to you
and follow that passion among the skills
many things what you're finding
of course you have to look at what are
the trends but that is more important
than looking at what is the top most
skill that is demand in market because
that will keep changing every five years
but if you find your passion
which is not skill based actually you
have to find your purpose and passion in
the career
which will be beyond a programming
language or a technology then you will
find keep finding answers and you will
transform yourself
that's my answer yeah and um
you and ashley had mentioned just before
the session started
um that we share a passion for
storytelling
and that's an example of a kind of
meta skill that is important across
almost everything people do today um
it's a communication technique because
humans evolved
to to really learn in two ways through
stories
and through songs and songs are just
stories that are set to music
um but if you're a good storyteller if
you develop a storytelling skill
that's going to serve you in any
field of endeavor engineers need to be
able to tell stories
to their customers to their bosses to
their teammates
um as well as leaders do so
again your passion may not be based in a
particular technology skill or what's
trending
um but it may have broader application
than you think
so um we're reaching the end of the hour
and i think we have
just the one last question i'd like to
ask um
guru prasad asks what is your
mantra in addition to ankara
uh what
couple of phrases would you give to
people
to conquer the emerging vuca world
that's another great question i'm glad
to answer see it's about the mindset
fundamentally
many times we imagine we have arrived in
life
it could be because of education it
could be because of the position title
or what work you are doing we think we
have arrived in life there is nothing
more to learn nothing more to do
if you change that mindset to
actually eternally learning that's what
comes back to
still i am learning from michelangelo
i'll go back there
i think that's the mindset required we
will remain still humble
and actually make a great career by
learning companies
wonderful um and unfortunately that's
all the time we have
for the q a um there are
more questions of course but um i
apologize that we won't be able to
get to all of them um but thank you so
much
tree for um what you've
shared with us and i'm going to ask the
audience
one more poll question and
talk about lifelong learning and what
are the what are the skills
right now that you're interested in
learning
so let me
open the poll
so of these skills because they're
this is you know of course oriented
towards
the digital world and you may be
interested in many other things
beyond that but out of these skills
which ones uh interest you most
and when will you start learning them is
it something that you're committing to
do
right now um
is it something that you're going to be
able to do soon or
is it just one of those things that
you'll do someday
and we have a few seconds left on the
[Music]
poll
so let's share the results
and data science and machine learning
as well as project management are things
that people are very interested in but
there's a broad
range and it's encouraging to see that
the most common answer here is that
people want to start right away
um because today is always a good
time to start so uh
with with that i'm going to again
thank you sri and allow you to to say
goodbye to the audience yeah it was my
pleasure
thanks to simplyland for giving me this
opportunity
and also the great audience you kept me
engaged with
good questions and interactive session
even though this is a virtual one i
enjoyed being with you
hope i could share some thoughts and
give you some insights
thank you very much enjoyed the whole
session
great and you see uh shari's linkedin
handle there that please reach out to
him as i mentioned he's a
consultant to startups so if that's
something that you're interested in i
know that we have an experienced
audience
and that's something that maybe on the
back of or front of people's minds
nowadays
um please reach out to him uh
i will also mention that simply learn
has sorry a
program called skill up and skill up is
a way
for you to get a flavor
for and acquire new skills in the
digital domain
we offer this free it's a lot of our
course content that's available for
self-study
i will again drop the
link to it into the chat window
give me a moment and
we'd also like to invite you to our next
webinar which will be about a week from
now
a week and a day from now um
if you're interested in fintech and
you're interested in artificial
intelligence
this is a great session it's
the intersection of ai trends and
fintech
and how they're changing uh digital
economy drop roles in that industry
and our speaker will be the ceo of wish
finn rishi mara
and i will drop into the chat window
right now
information about how to enroll in that
but you can also find that on our
website i believe
and last i'd like to invite everyone
to connect with us through our social
media channels
on facebook twitter linkedin
and we operate globally
so wherever you are in the world
we'd love to connect with you and help
you on your career journey
and with that we've reached the end of
our
webinar so one last thank you to
sri again thank you to the audience
and uh this would be the time if you log
off now please do answer the poll
questions that will pop up in your
browser
and we look forward to seeing you at
future simply learn webinars
thanks again thank you very much
you